bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
moi sur rt france qu'est ce qui a changé
aux états unis depuis la mort de
dangereuses il ya un nom on écoute et je
pense que ce sont plus les prises de
conscience et peut-être l'émergence
d'une forme de consensus dans la
population qui aura encore besoin de
temps pour se traduire comme l'excellent
exposé que vous venez de faire un lien
très complet le montre besoin de temps
pour se traduire dans des législations
car le diable c'est toujours dans les
détails il faut descendre vers la
gratuité la plus fine
c'est à dire échelle des comptes et
qu'ils soient circonscription qui
constituent les états là où le shérif
sont tenus par exemple un 18001 service
ou poste de police chacun avec c'est un
véritable patchwork ce système américain
est donc c'est à cette échelle là qu'il
faudra décembre barack obama d'ailleurs
avait signalé que la participation lors
des élections le magistrat de shérif de
responsables de police à travers le pays
y compris par les 18 25 ou 30 ans mais
d'une manière globale la participation
électorale était très faible
donc vous voyez qu'il faut le tamis est
à ses fins il faut descendre vers les
spécificités parfois territoriales pour
que cette prise de conscience à travers
mes événements un peu spectaculaire et
tragique que l'on a vécu l'année
dernière et les violences auxquelles ça
a donné lieu devienne change la réalité
qui repose sur une chose en particulier
je lirai hessel ne se rappelle proxim
c'est à dire la codification de
l'exercice du métier de policier en
particulier ne les interpréter les acca
par contre les interpellations
donc le jaune sur le coup elle est une
des mains des éléments en particulier
lusage de larmes aussi votre reportage
très bien parler par exemple tiré sur
une voiture en mouvement dès lors qu'il
n'ya pas de danger de mort imminent ce
sont tous ces détails là qui ne sont pas
malheureusement dans les mains
du pouvoir fédéral ni du congrès qui
peut légiférer par exemple sur la
réglementation pour le port d'armes
types d'armes que l'on peut avoir chez
soi ou que l'on peut apporter en liberté
dans la rue par exemple et tout le reste
comme ça a été très bien dit ça dépend
des villes des comtés et les états et
avec dernier point cet élément
particulier aux états unis si les
statistiques montrent que les noirs deux
fois plus et demi plus de chances d'être
la cible de violences policières de tir
c'est aussi parce qu'il ya une
représentation beaucoup plus importante
de la population noire américaine dans
la délinquance et dans les prisons
américaines et on revient la ressource
du sujet qui est au fond ce qui pourrait
s'apparenter à ce qu'on appelle en
france la question des banlieues c'est à
dire le chômage la délinquance la drogue
l'absence d'avenir
la déstructuration des cellules
familiales avec beaucoup de femmes afro
américaine seul foyer avec des enfants
difficile de les éduquer lorsqu'elle le
diable par la queue et une situation
très difficile toute la journée avec un
travail d'un côté les enfants de l'autre
bref tout ce tissu social là qui est le
contexte de fond qui est
particulièrement marquée pour les
populations américaines mois ce qui
explique la statistique
effectivement ces surprenantes mais
encore une fois tout tout seul tous et
tout s'explique
voilà donc ce qui vous évoquez une prise
de conscience est ce que sur les le
terrain les pratiques policières
en général on a évolué en un an
je pense que c'est trop rapide de votre
reportage a très bien noté qu'il ya un
certain nombre de choses qui ont évolué
plus d'état au plus deux villes qui ont
pris des mesures pour interdire le type
d'arrestation la technique ni
mobilisation du tibia du genou
sur le coup qui peut empêcher de
respirer surtout si bien qu'avec
d'obèses et les problèmes de santé etc
on a vu ça c'est vraiment une une
granularité qui qui fait appel aux
territoires et la codification du métier
de policier qu'on peut pas non plus
totalement à encadrer rigidifier ski
alors il se donnerait inefficace
particulièrement dans un pays où quand
même lorsque vous portait d'uniforme
vous avez de bonnes chances aussi de
vous faire tirer dessus voire de mourir
puisque le port d'armes est libre dans
la plupart des états aux états unis oui
que cetad c'est à double double face si
je puis dire il faut codifié d'un côté
sans rendre le métier j'ai pu lire un
praticable mais loin il ya beaucoup de
marche donc des raisons pour lesquelles
à la loi une loi contre les violences
policières semble bloquée au congrès
parce que sur le terrain les choses sont
beaucoup plus difficiles à mettre en
oeuvre
c'est plus difficile à mettre en oeuvre
la limite je dirais que c'est plus
facile de les adopter et c'est cette
régularité là qui est plus accessible au
fond parce que ça dépend des mers et ça
dépend des assemblées locales de vous
placer au congrès sur des lois comme
celle là je vous entraîne directement
dans l'affrontement bipartisans entre un
parti républicain qui est un petit peu
sorti du cadre depuis une quinzaine
d'années et qui n'est plus du tout le
parti républicain traditionnel et qui
est un parti en ré invention
malheureusement ça ne prend pas là
spécialement la bonne voie sont utiles
ces jours ci est un parti démocrate qui
a lui aussi d'ailleurs ces rigidités
idéologique c'est bien pour ça qu'un
byden permet de si je puis dire de
d'assouplir un peu les choses mais très
vite vous en prêts aux états unis au
congrès à washington dans un
affrontement frontal une bipolarisation
fort de la vie politique qui rend
si on fait graver difficile merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
yannick mireur je rappelle que êtes
politologue spécialiste des états unis